- Good morning, everyone.
Can everybody hear me well?
Give me a thumbs up.
Okay.
So remember this is a silent room.
Don't forget to put your headphones on.
So welcome to Las Vegas.
Welcome to re:Invent 2025.
We make it.
I can believe
it's already December,
and today, this is the session CNS 417
for Network Observability and Strategies.
And on this session we'll be
guiding you through a journey
to achieve observability
and improve your overall security posture
on Kubernetes environment by
simplifying overall operations
and application lifecycle, right?
So we want to simplify our
daily tasks so we can be more,
achieve more velocity and
faster time to market.
One thing to keep in mind is we want
to make sure that all the features
that are coming out is, have that goal
to simplify your overall operations.
And today we are now
seeing a very nice feature
that I wish was there when
I was a platform engineering
managing a lot of Kubernetes environments.
So how many of you are using
Kubernetes in production today?
Give me a show of hands.
So nice.
Basically everybody.
How many of you are
aware of EKS Auto Mode?
Nice.
So we'll be covering some features
that cover overall EKS overall Kubernetes,
but also how EKS Auto Mode
can help you simplifying
those daily operations.
My name is Rodrigo Bersa.
I'm a Container Specialist
Solutions Architect at AWS,
and my goal here is to help
customers overcome challenges
and build solutions
to simplify their daily activities.
And I have the pleasure to
have here with me Master Luke.
He's not Luke's Sky Walker,
but he's also a Master Jedi in Kubernetes.
- Thanks, Rodrigo.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Lukonde Mwila, you
can also call me Luke,
and I'm a Product Manager
on the Amazon EKS team.
So I wanna start by
asking a quick question.
By show of hands, does
this architecture diagram
resemble your environment to some degree,
at least at the fundamental layer?
You can see a couple of hands going up.
Okay, more going up.
That's great.
So this is something that
we put in front of a lot
of customers, and many of
them were able to resonate
with this, and again, emphasizing
on the fundamental layer.
And what we have represented here
is a application environment
that has Amazon EKS
as the foundation for its platform.
And this is what a lot
of customers are doing.
Now, it's not the entire picture,
and that's something that we're going
to be taking you on a journey about.
You have a lot of Kubernetes workloads,
or to be more specific,
microservices that are running
on EKS, and a lot of
these are communicating
with each other in order to
drive business functionality.
These microservices are speaking
to each other within the
scope of the cluster.
So there's a lot of east to west traffic.
Now, in addition to that, a lot
of these microservices also
rely on AWS infrastructure.
For example, you could
be running some kind
of storage application that relies on S3s
to actually storage objects there.
And then in order to have
some metadata associated
with those objects, you could
be storing it in DynamoDB,
or perhaps you're using a
traditional three tier application
and you're using Elastic Cache
as the caching layer, RDS
or DocumentDB for persistent storage.
We also have a lot of
customers that are training
their ML models and using
S3 four checkpointing,
but again, it doesn't stop there.
A lot of customers are also
integrating these environments
with additional services
and systems that are running
on-prem or on the internet.
Does this pattern sound familiar?
Again, any show of hands on that?
So what we have here in the bigger picture
is this widely distributed
environment with a lot of threads
that essentially tie
back to EKS as the hub
or one of the primary hubs.
And the core fabric that ties all
of this together is the network.
And the more that companies
or organizations continue to innovate
and introduce additional enhancements,
that will typically translate
to new microservices
that land either in your EKS
cluster or perhaps on-prem
or some other service on the internet,
but still ties back to
this foundational layer.
And so in such environments,
it is becoming increasingly
critical to understand
the landscape of the network,
to understand its security, to understand
its performance and its behavior
primarily so you can
measure how well that aligns
with your internal standards,
because the goal at the end
of the day is to optimize it
so that it's serving the
ultimate purpose of driving
the kind of business value that you want.
This should ultimately be
serving that bigger purpose,
but that becomes especially difficult
if you have limited visibility.
You can't accurately
optimize what you can't see.
Some additional challenges to be aware of,
especially in the context
of an EKS environment.
When you're running a Kubernetes
cluster in AWS, you have
to be mindful of the fact that you have
a broader network plane
and that is the VPC.
But in addition to that,
Kubernetes also has
its own network plane.
So you essentially have two landscapes
or two network planes,
which introduces
additional operational
complexity on your part.
And if you're trying to
achieve that objective
that I pointed out earlier of optimizing
for security, performance
and ensuring that application's
traffic behavior aligns
with your internal standards
or designs, you need to be able
to consolidate these two planes
and easily understand the data points
between the two of them.
And as I've already spoken about,
network observability is multidimensional.
You're concerned about network
observability with respect
to security, performance,
cost optimization
and ensuring that behavior aligns
with applications that you have designed.
Are the right applications talking
to each other as expected?
These are key things.
And so the main thing
that we do wanna draw out in
terms of the problem definition
to begin with is that when
you have a lack of visibility
or limited visibility, you
end up with imprecise data.
And the challenge with
having imprecise data
is you have inaccurate conclusions
and slow decision-making.
And finally, that leads
to suboptimal actions.
Any platform engineers
that can relate to this?
And you get, you get
stuck in a loop of trying
to figure out exactly
what a root cause is,
and fundamentally it's because
of a lack of visibility,
and that also eventually ties
to a negative impact on the business.
There are many scenarios
in which the business
is ultimately disrupted
because of some kind
of network issue.
It could be congestion at the pod layer,
specifically an ENI issue.
But without sufficient visibility
and data, it's hard to actually
detect that in a quick way.
What you're interested
in is reducing the amount
of time it takes to
quickly detect an issue
so that you can fast-track
resolving it as well.
Or perhaps maybe it's a
bandwidth issue related
to the specific worker node.
But again, that requires having
sufficient network visibility
at both a pod level
and a worker node level
and having enough context so
that when you detect an issue,
you're also quickly able to tie it
to the relevant metadata.
What cluster is this coming from?
What namespace is this coming from?
What is the workload associated with this?
And exactly what pod is this tied to?
What are the ENIs
associated with this pod?
There's also the challenge
of increasing costs
when you have insufficient visibility.
A lot of customers try to
adopt different strategies
and techniques to manage
the flow of traffic.
Anyone can relate to that here?
Yep.
One of the key things when it comes
to cost optimization is trying to ensure
that when traffic is flowing
from a particular workload
to a certain destination,
you try to ensure
that that traffic ends up
in the same AZ in which
it originated from.
And there are different
ways of doing this.
You can use native functionalities
to Kubernetes like topology aware routing.
We also know that a lot of
customers use Istio for this,
for locality-based routing,
or you can even use Envoy for this.
But again, how can you quickly verify
that those optimizations
that you've put in place
actually are working as expected?
How can you review the topology setup
in your Kubernetes environment
and verify that the flows
are working as expected
based on certain techniques
that you would've put in place?
And then finally, there's the
impact of security as well,
which is fundamental,
and Rodrigo's gonna be diving
into this even further,
which also impacts the time to market.
Again, as I mentioned earlier, the point
is to ultimately deliver
business value faster,
and it's hard to confidently do that
if security is unsure
about how well the
network has been optimized
to meet certain internal standards,
that it complies as expected.
Our traffic patterns
aligning with the designs
that were set up for
specific applications.
Is workload A speaking to
workload B is expected?
And based on the designs, ensuring
that workload C should not be receiving
any traffic from workload C.
How quickly can you verify that
so that you have sufficient
confidence to move from dev
to stage to prod?
Rodrigo, where do we go from here?
- Yes, you have one slide.
- Right.
(Rodrigo laughs)
Almost missed this one.
Another reason why this is
so important is because this
is an increasing trend.
We have a lot of customers
that are using microservice architectures,
and of course it introduces
its own challenges,
but we don't want to
take a step away from it
because of those challenges.
And so we have to be
mindful of these hurdles,
but at the same time,
the key thing on our part
is how do we simplify
operations on your part
so that as you adopt a usage pattern
that certainly has a number
of advantages, in this case
microservice architectures,
how do we ensure that the kind of way,
the ways in which we are
simplifying the operations
in your life helps you
to continue the trend
or leaning into specific usage
patterns that you're trying
to adopt in your EKS environments?
And that is gonna be a key thing
that we'll speak about here,
and Rodrigo already alluded to earlier.
- So where do we go from here?
So how do we translate those kinds
of business challenges
to technical solutions?
Right?
Because if we think about it,
they're not really business challenges.
They are technical
challenges that are leading
to business challenges.
So let's bring back that architecture
that Luke just showed us,
but let's dive deep on the core center
or our Amazon EKS cluster,
our Kubernetes cluster.
Because if you think about
it, the communication
through storage or to a database,
it was always, always there?
Like it doesn't matter what kind
of application you have,
it's running on EC2
or if it's containerized,
but the growing trend of those
containerized applications
and multi-tenant applications
is what's causing
this complexity to increase over and over.
So how did we get
to like this very complex
microservices scenario?
Let's start from the beginning.
So the multi-tenancy evolution
started with monolith.
So we had one team
or two teams managing
one specific application.
There's nothing much to do.
Like there's, it's just
one piece, a black box.
They don't have like too much interaction,
they don't have too much
connection like microservices.
With the growing trend of Kubernetes,
we started containerizing those monoliths,
not really in the right way, we just make
those big applications containers
and we put in a cluster,
like a single tenant cluster.
So this is what we call
like hard multi-tenancy
where you have like
one application running
in a specific cluster.
And this is not wrong.
Like this is maybe required if you have
like a very PCI compliant environment
or if you have like specific
security restrictions.
But then we started learning
that Kubernetes very,
very effective on managing
multiple workloads.
So we transitioned
basically to two patterns.
We have one cluster with
multiple applications segregated
by this logical pieces called namespace,
as we call it soft multi-tenancy.
And the other pattern is when you have
like several applications
running in the same namespace,
sharing the same namespace.
But how can we ensure
that we have security among all of them?
We usually start seeing
that this is like an overly
permissive environment
because we're not controlling this.
Are we sure that the application A
can communicate to application B?
We're not.
And then these are concerns
about like the development
or application teams,
and they're not really the,
to keep security is not
really their main focus
or to keep like this access control.
So there's one team
missing on this picture,
which is the platform
team or the security team.
The security team and the platform team,
they are responsible for
all of those environments
to like help control access
to help like make sure it's
secure to avoid outages,
whereas our application
teams want to develop fast,
they want to experiment, they
want faster time to market,
they want to speed up
application lifecycle.
And as Luke mentioned,
if the security team doesn't
have like clear visibility,
it's really hard for them to create a,
for the platform team to
have a secure environment,
and then it creates like an
overly permissive environment,
like I said, because if
the security teams put
like too much restriction, they
block the application teams
and it's not good for anyone.
So how do we strike this
balance to have control
and security that's required
for like high regulated environments
and have team autonomy so the teams,
the development teams can be efficient?
Usually, like I said, we fall back
into an overly permissive environment
because there's no like visibility
across networking
communications and we don't want
to block the development.
Does this resonates to like
anyone's environment here?
Anyone's like application
lifecycle process?
Okay, but where do we
really want to go is here.
So we want to have assertive
controls so we are secure
and we are efficient at the same time.
And how can AWS help?
Like I said, our goal is to
simplify overall operations
and overall application life cycle.
So we started tackling a layered approach
to cover all of that.
So starting from the bottom, we want
to simplify overall
infrastructure management,
so platform engineers can really
focus on what's important.
We want to give you full clarity
and full visibility of
all the network paths
and everything that's
happening in your environment
so you can achieve an improved
overall security posture,
which is like one of
the most critical pieces
of everyone's environment.
So starting from the bottom again,
last year at re:Invent we
introduced it EKS Auto Mode.
Remember I talked about Auto Mode.
I know some of you already using it.
And what Auto Mode gives you.
So it's basically one
click create cluster,
and all of the production-ready
best practices,
capabilities are out of the box.
So you don't need to be word
about deploying any of those.
It provisions all the
cluster infrastructure
and automatically does compute scalability
through a key piece company
that's called Karpenter.
Everybody here knows what Karpenter is?
Nice.
So just a quick quick recap
for those who don't know.
Karpenter is a node out scaler
that scales out compute research
based on research requests.
So you have like pending pods,
Karpenter will read those
and in a few seconds it
you spin up any compute
that's required for those workloads
to run based on cost efficiency
and performance efficiency.
And it uses like basically two components
that are completely customizable,
and it's managed entirely
inside Kubernetes.
You don't need to be worried
about managed note groups,
out-scaling groups, whatever.
So together with that like Karpenter
also continuously optimized for cost.
So it just doesn't scale resources,
it optimizes your overall environment.
And then the part that's most important
for this session, Auto Mode
comes with core components
for networking, and we'll be talking
about those three components in a bit,
but also it keeps like all
of those components updated
to patch and security
fixes on the AWS side.
So this way is like
where we started creating
a simplified infrastructure
baseline for you.
So let's talk about like
those three components,
start from the edges.
So CoreDNS and kube-proxy
are very well known components
from the Kubernetes world.
So CoreDNS basically, name
resolution inside your cluster
so you don't need to like be memorizing
IP addresses of course.
And kube-proxy is the component
that understands the egress
and ingress communication
and know hows to direct
the right communication
to the right pods because
you have like a couple
of VNIs probably in your nodes
but you have like a 100 pods.
So kube-proxy we will
do like this transition
and direct the the the
traffic to the right pod.
And in the middle we have like the CNI.
Okay, CNI is one of the
most important parts
for our session today.
So CNI, there are a lot
of CNIs out there on
the open source world,
but last year,
in fact in 2023, we released
it like native support
for network policies on CNI
where in the past you need
to use like a third
party CNI to have access
to all the network capabilities
in your Kubernetes cluster.
How many of you are using
actually using network policies?
Just a few.
So that's, that's, that's really common
because doing network
policies is not easy.
Why?
Because you don't have that kind
of visibility like ease
to west communication part
to part namespace who communicates to who?
All of these components
run in inside the node
and you don't need to
to manage all of them.
So let's talk a little bit
more about network policies
which will improve the security
posture of the cluster.
So in the past before Auto Mode,
there's a custom setup required
for you to enable those network policies.
You need to be worried about
roles and how to enable that.
And this could cause like a
cluster level blast radius
where in EKS Auto Mode it's
like much more streamlined.
Network policies are enabled by default.
You just need to tell them to use it.
So basically you, you need
to create a config map,
and say hey, I want to
use network policies.
Boom, it'll be there.
Then one of the components for Karpenter
that helps you manage the
nodes is the node class, right?
So you have the node
class, it's pretty simple,
it's baseline infrastructure
and then you can define
the default behavior
of your network policies.
By default it comes with allow policies,
but you can change that
to default deny if you
want to, like I said,
if you're running high
regulated environments
and also you can separate
specific node classes.
So I want to have one application
that's fully isolated
from the rest of them,
the the applications that
are running in my cluster.
You don't need to create another cluster.
You can do that like in the compute level,
in the same cluster using EKS Auto Mode
and network policies.
So don't take my word.
Let's just create a really
quick one EKS Auto Cluster here
for the sake of the presentation.
Like I said, we are going
into a very quick journey.
So let's create like a one cluster.
I just put the name,
I see we don't have the role
specific for that cluster.
You can just click a button,
it'll come like with
all the best practices,
granular list privilege for the cluster,
and you just few clicks you
have the recommended role
to create a cluster in your environment.
Secondarily, we have the node role.
So node role in cluster roll,
they have different personas,
so they need to have like
different level of access.
So we can create the same way
that we did for the cluster.
So few clicks, create roll,
we have the node roll running,
(audience clapping)
and then let's go to the network part.
So because of the way that Auto Mode runs,
you can create a very,
a specific network for your cluster.
Like all the best practices will be there,
just click create VPC.
The only things that
I'll be changing, I want
to run in three AZs, not just two.
And I want to use like this
new feature for a regional net.
So with that like I'll be like
in a few minutes I can create
like a cluster rolls and VPC all together
for my environment.
As you see, like all
of that will be created
in a few minutes.
The only thing that takes a little bit
is that gateway to be
there and propagated.
But then we have like
now IM rolls networks
with subnets, everything ready,
and also Auto Mode knows that we want
to run the pods just on
the private networks.
We don't want to have pods
on public-facing networks
with public IP addresses.
So we are protecting
our pods like by design.
And if you want to dive deep there,
like there's some specific
configurations that you can go,
like all the pods and service
networking are already there,
and there's some stuff
that you can opt out
after you create your cluster.
So pretty, pretty easy,
pretty straightforward.
Now we have a cluster running.
In a few minutes,
like we'll have like the cluster
activating than creating.
One thing that I want to
mention is the only add-on
that will be created
is the metrics server.
So all the other add-ons like
for core network capabilities,
Karpenter, port identity,
everything is embedded in the cluster
to simplify your daily operations.
The only thing that you see
there is the metric server
that's not embedded,
but metric server is required
to have like that scalability
and the cost optimization
that we talked about.
So we see clusters there already active.
Now let's enable the network
policy on this cluster.
So the cluster comes
with the network policy already there
on as a capability from the EKS CNI.
But we need to tell
them on the, like I said
on that specific config map that we want
to use network policies.
So we just have like those two pods.
Everything is away,
because the goal of EKS
Auto Mode is for you
to just deploy your applications.
So like you said, like like you saw,
like there's nothing there
other than the metrics server
and the nodes where the
metrics server is running.
So let's see the node class where I show
the, that configuration
for the default behavior
of the network policy.
So let's take a look on
that configuration file.
I'll just filter the
output so it's easier.
We don't have like a big one.
So we have network policy as fallout
and event logs are disabled by default.
Event logs is just to
everything that happens,
everything that matches a
network policy will be logged
on the Kubernetes Events log.
So I have like this manifest already done
and I'll just create it.
Just double checking is not there yet.
I'll just be enabling
that specific config map so we can have
network policy support fully
enabled in the cluster.
So we cover like this, this bottom part
for simplifying overall infrastructure
with those core components,
and being able to enable network policies.
Let's talk a little bit
more about network policies.
Like I said, this was introduced
in 2023 as native feature
for EKS CNI, and it works
a little bit different
from the standard network
policy that you can get
from the community.
So it's a single plugin, fully
integrated, you don't need
to deploy anything else,
and uses EBPF to be
performant as it is today.
Quick recap on what's EBPF.
So EBPF means like Extended
Berkeley Package Filter,
but it's basically a kernel engine
or a kernel module that's enabled
and filter all the SIS calls
that's happening from the user.
So you have like an application
or anything that does a
SIS call, EBPF will inspect
that package and then go back
to the Linux kernel after inspected.
This is like very common use case
for load balancing security and tracing.
But our goal here for
network policy is security,
but we'll be talking,
but we'll be using EBPF
for tracing as well,
but I don't want to spoil the surprise
that Luke will be presenting.
And how does it work under the hood?
So a user can create a network policy.
The network policy controller will read it
and trigger an endpoint CRD
that's exclusive for EKS CNI,
and then EKS CNI, using EBPF
we'll inspect that package
and decide, hey, should I apply
a network policy restriction
or isolation here are not?
When we do like this, this kind of changes
and we apply network policies
and change the default
behavior for that node class,
a specific rollout happens.
So we cover the EC2 node class
in the previous slides,
and the other component from
Karpenter is the node pool.
So the node pool defines the behavior
whereas the node class defines
the baseline infrastructure for the nodes.
So we're just getting
like this one isolated.
The disruption that I'm highlighting
on the slide is just the way
that the rollout will be, will happen.
So for example, I want to disrupt just 10%
of my nodes at a time.
Let's say I have like a huge
environment, it'll not disrupt
and roll out and apply network policies
or any other behavior for
more than 10% at a time.
So this is just an example.
You can do like 1%, 50%,
and a node expires from
time to time to renew
the, the nodes and apply new patches
and new configurations like I said.
So let's see this in action.
This is the cluster that we just created.
Now, what I'll do, I will
deploy an application here.
So this application consists
like a few name spaces, few deployments.
I'll just use like customization
for the sake of time.
Of course we should be
using like GitHub's approach
for this, but this is a talk
for for next year maybe.
So I created all of the
resource components.
We have our application running.
And because the policies that fall out,
everything communicates to everything.
Remember, overly permissive environment.
So we can just get like all the pods.
Now, let's get like the, the URL for us
to access this application,
see if it's really
running and if it's there
and behaving as expected.
So let's get this, let's
paste on our browser.
We have just a specific secret shop
we can buy like anything here.
Let's just do explore.
So we have on this
application, we have this UI,
we have a catalog for all the
products, we have the cards
and we have the orders.
So all of those pieces need
to be communicating together
in order for this shop to really work.
So now what we're going to do, we're going
to apply a default NI
policy for this environment,
and let's see what happens.
So remember today's the fallout.
Let's change this to a default NI policy
and wait for Karpenter to do the rollout
of all the nodes.
For the sake of time,
like i, I cut like the
part of the the the rollout
because it takes like a few minutes,
but you see like the, it, it
won't take more than than three
to five minutes on the the pod history.
So let's change the
network policy for the NI
and enable the event logs
so we can see what's actually happening
on the event logs if we need.
So done.
Let's watch for the nodes behavior.
We didn't trigger like the nose
have like around 20 minutes.
Now let's watch.
In a few seconds you
everything will be triggered
and you see like new nodes running
with the new configuration.
So this is what the rollout is about.
So see we have like a new
node, like this is the time
that Karpenter takes
to spin up a new node.
It's really, really fast.
Now let's go to our application and check.
It doesn't seem to be running.
So on this time, you
receive a call from your CEO
or from a financial
person that will say, hey,
our application is offline.
Whatever you have done, just roll it back.
We have like the new nodes there
and the applications are not
like really communicating.
So what we are going to do, we see,
you see like the applications
weren't even able to spin up
because there's no
communication, live-ness probe,
redness probe, everything just failed.
And how do we investigate
this if we don't have
like proper visibility on the network?
Even if we have access to
the logs, is not traceable.
We don't have like all clear visibility
on who's communicating to who
to approve like this, this configuration.
So let's do what like our other team ask
and then go back to an overly
permissive environment,
and this will sit there forever.
Like the application will go back running,
but then how can we fix those things
to be back to a controlled environment
with our application
running in an efficient way?
Right?
So how do we control access?
Let's say we go back to the default NI
and then we need to apply a network policy
to open the communication to the orders,
namespace from the catalog,
from the UI namespace, right?
So you can see like this is
a, this is a quick example
of a network policy.
So on the spec we have
like the pod selector.
So all the orders, pods on the
order name space is allowed
to receive ingress communication
from the UI as you see in the bottom.
But then you need to open
for the checkout as well,
and then you need to go to the UI
and say hey UI, you need, you can go
to these two name spaces and
then you need another policy
and another policy.
And then what about DNS resolution?
Do I need to open
communication to the CoreDNS
so I can have name resolution?
Do the spots need to access internet?
Who talks to who?
And all of these questions
falls into the platform team
because they don't have visibility.
Even if the application teams knows
where their application is going,
they usually don't know
who's accessing them.
So how do you overcome that
if we don't have proper visibility?
So we cover like the top layer
to improve overall security, right?
But if we go
to an overly restricted
environment, things break.
Something's still missing.
Can you help me out with this one, Luke?
- Absolutely.
So as Rodrigo pointed out, it's very hard
to accurately optimize
without sufficient visibility.
You can have the capabilities
but normally what ends
up happening is a lot
of customers end up bouncing
between two extremes,
overly permissive and overly restrictive,
and that's what impacts
their environments.
So there's a critical
layer that is needed,
and that's the missing
piece from the diagram
that Rodrigo just showed,
and that is essentially observability.
And we're really excited
for this new feature
that we recently launched.
Container network observability in EKS.
And this is a key
or fundamental aspect to
achieving the right kind
of optimization you want for security,
as Rodrigo's been emphasizing
on, but also for performance
and also for cost,
and ensuring that traffic
behavior in the cluster
aligns with design.
This allows you to essentially have
your ES network environment
a lot more observable,
which is very important when it comes
to successfully scaling in
widely distributed environments.
You need to be able to track east
to west traffic within
the scope of the cluster
but also you wanna be able
to track traffic between pods
and certain AWS services.
In addition to that, as I
saw some hands raised, a lot
of you are also running
applications in the cluster
that are speaking to
services outside the scope
of AWS as a whole.
Now, there's some key ways
that this new feature can
essentially enable you
or empower you in this particular regard.
I wanna focus on the use cases
before we get into the
specific feature sets
with container network observability.
So a first one
that I wanna touch on is
measuring network performance.
So this is, this is especially important
because this is something that
a lot of customers run into,
to be more specific
platform teams, being able
to quickly pinpoint where
an issue originated from.
A lot of teams have already standardized
on their observability stack
and a lot of customers will
essentially be sending data
from their Kubernetes
cluster or their EKS cluster
to some kind of observability stack,
and that may be managed
solutions within AWS.
You could be using CloudWatch,
you could be using
Amazon managed Prometheus
and Amazon managed Grafana,
or you could be using
open source solutions
and managing them yourself
with Prometheus and Grafana.
And so this was especially
important for us to ensure
that if we're going to
enable our customers
in the right kind of way,
then we need to align
with your usage patterns.
And so we're providing
more key metrics now
that are a lot more
granular at the pod level
and the worker node level that
are related to networking,
allowing you to quickly pinpoint issues
like network congestion at
a pod level, seeing the enis
that are associated with that, being able
to quickly determine
if there was a bandwidth exhaustion issue
in a specific worker node,
whether it was related
to ingress or egress, being
able to track the flow count
for pods, and being able
to see in a very quick way
what the particular issue is.
And that reduces the mean
time to detection as well
as mean time to resolution,
which is extremely important
when incidents arise.
Measuring your net,
the network performance
to detect anomalies.
And in many cases customers
essentially have thresholds
that they'll set,
and once that threshold gets breached,
they can proactively respond
to these issues before they get worse.
Now, in addition to that, what we've seen
is that is normally the starting point.
You'll have some kind
of observability stack
where some alert or alarm will notify you,
but after that, there's a
tail end of the investigation.
You wanna wait to scope
down the particular area
where the issue originated from,
you wanna double-click on it essentially
and then carry your
chair of investigations.
Now, sometimes this can
be especially painful
if you're solely relying
on TCP dump in the cluster.
Can anyone relate to that?
That can be a lengthy and painful
and costly process as well.
And so we thought it
was especially important
to provide additional
capabilities for the tail end
of the investigation as well,
something that compliments
proactive anomaly detection
with whatever observability
stack you're already using.
And so there are now native
visualizations in the cluster
as well that you can make use
of, being able to track east
to west traffic within the
scope of the cluster, traffic
between pods and AWS services.
At launch we support traffic
between pods and S3 as well as DynamoDB,
but then also being able to
see pods that are speaking
to a cluster external destinations
and more specific
destinations outside the scope
of AWS as a whole.
You can also leverage these
native console capabilities
to track the top talkers.
That's something that a lot of customers
are particularly interested in.
What are the workloads
responsible for the most traffic
that is being sent within the scope
of the cluster or outside the cluster?
Being able to see traffic
that is traversing
different availability zones.
How do you verify accurately
that the cost optimization techniques
that you're adopting are
actually working as expected?
And so a lot of what
I've been speaking about
is essentially captured
in this diagram over here.
We essentially took a closer
look at the usage pattern
among our customers, and we
didn't want want platform teams
to have to deviate to fit into a new norm,
but rather how can we make
the EKS network environment
more observable aligning
with what customers
are already practicing?
And so what you'll see is teams
will essentially be relying
on data that they can leverage
to measure performance.
That is a key one for a lot of customers.
How do we accurately measure
the network performance
in our environment?
And so you've already got
some observability stack.
And so the new metrics
that we're providing
are available in open metrics format,
and EKS is using Amazon
CloudWatch Network Monitoring.
So this is a feature that
was launched last year,
and so we partnered
together to further align
with EKS use cases.
And so CloudWatch Network
Monitoring has an EBPF agent
that runs on the worker nodes
and it captures the network
flows, to be more specific,
the top 500 network flows
on every worker node
as well as the flow metrics associated
with each of those flows.
And so we have two sets of metrics.
We have system metrics
as well as flow metrics.
The system metrics can be scraped directly
from the worker node and sent
to your preferred monitoring solution.
So if you are using
Prometheus, for example,
then you can directly scrape
these from the NFM agent.
Alternatively, you may be
using Amazon-managed Prometheus
and you could use a scrape
list mechanism as well
to essentially ingest those.
Now, the tail end of it, as
I pointed out, you'll see
that there's an arrow
from the platform team
that's also going to the EKS console,
and that is where you'll essentially find
the additional capabilities
that we are now providing
to help you in accelerating
and having more precise troubleshooting.
Now, I think what you're
looking forward to seeing
is what this actually
looks like in action.
And so if you're using the
console to enable this feature,
you would essentially just
click this one button over here
or this checkbox rather to
enable network monitoring
and it will automatically create
the underlying dependencies
that are in CloudWatch
network flow monitoring.
And we've documented these
clearly for you to see
exactly what will be provided
and we'll also guide
you through the process
of installing the relevant NFM add-on.
Now, in this case over
here it's already enabled,
and so you can also see the
capabilities over there.
There's a service map and a flow table
and those are provided in the console.
The performance metrics
endpoint is something
that you can leverage
and directly scrape from.
We can see the status
over here of the monitor.
So from what we gather,
everything looks like it's
already set up and enabled,
and so we're gonna follow the
normal workflow that a lot
of customers already use.
And so the starting point
is typically you've got
your own observability
stack as I pointed out.
So this is a Grafana dashboard
over here, which is something
that a lot of customers rely on already.
They're already standardized
on using Grafana and so
we fit right into that.
And so over here this is a dashboard
that actually visualizes
all the key metrics
that we're providing now, and
you can see the top 10 pods
by ingress bandwidth,
and this allows you to
actually track these things.
We've had a lot of customers
speak to us to say,
how can I easily understand the amount
of bandwidth being leveraged
by CoreDNS, for example?
'Cause that's a critical
component that lots
pods are essentially
communicating with in order
to resolve their
communication with other pods.
We can do the same for
egress bandwidth as well.
We can look at the ingress
bandwidth allowance exceeded
and detect any anomalies
associated with the worker nodes,
and we've got the metadata
that you can capture
that is captured here as well.
And you can see that in
your Grafana dashboard now.
Everything consolidated in one place
fitting right into your
existing usage pattern.
We can also see the
packets per second allow
and succeeded, connection
tracking allow and succeeded,
and you can see the all the worker nodes
that this is associated with.
And the key thing here again
is to further enable you
to easily detect an issue
and trace it back to the specific point
of origin without having
a long stretch in getting
to what the issue actually is,
detecting it as well as resolving it.
You also have the ability now
to track the egress bandwidth
for your pods as well as the
ingress bandwidth, ensuring
that this aligns with what you expect,
or if you need to be
modifying your environment,
to align with usage by
your customers as well.
We can see as well for the TCP flow count
for the different pods.
We can see the packet rate
from ingress rate as well
as egress as well for the pods.
Drilling in more and more and
giving you more granularity
so that you have sufficient information.
And as Rodrigo pointed out,
before we get to the point
of optimizing things, we need
to have this detailed layer of visibility
that can give us informed decision-making
and that empowers it,
empowers our customers
or enables them even better
to be able to respond quickly
to issues when they arise.
Now, the next thing that follows
after this is you may
get some kind of page
or alert that would happen,
and you would have sufficient information
to then zone in on a specific cluster.
Now, in this case we have
a very basic e-commerce application
that uses the GraphQL API
and this is just showing again
that this is already enabled.
So I'm gonna switch back and we're looking
at the service map now,
and this is specific to
the e-commerce namespace.
We've got three microservices here.
We have a GraphQL API that
speaks to an orders application
and a products application.
You can change time if
you need to scope it
to a one-hour session
or if you want to reduce that
to five minutes to see what's happening.
We can click on any one of these flows.
And then what we see
here is forward direction
as well as reverse direction in the case
that there is bidirectional traffic.
We can zone in even further
'cause this is the kind of granularity
that becomes extremely useful,
being able to see the flow
between pods that are actually talking
to each other at a specific replica level.
And because this can be
a bit noisy, for example,
for the last one hour
or the last 30 minutes,
you can also change this
if you want it to be
for the last five minutes.
And again, you can zone in further
and see the amount of data
that was transferred on
these specific flows.
And this is where the
flow metrics come in.
You can also see retransmissions
and retransmission timeouts.
If you're trying to detect
latency for example,
the higher your retransmission timeouts,
the more you see a
significant impact of latency
between specific pods,
and you'll be able to use
these kinds of capabilities for that.
Let's drill in even further.
We can go to view details
and what we have over here
is actually a flow table
that allows us to see at a
more granular level the flows
for the different pods that are talking
to each other in this specific namespace.
You can filter for more
granularity and precision.
Say we wanna look at flows
for where the local pod
is is a GraphQL pod,
and we can scroll to the side there again,
we can still see each of
those flow level metrics.
Retransmissions, retransmission
timeouts for remote pod.
In this case I'm going to choose orders.
And there we see the
amount of data transferred.
And you can see right at the top
there we've also got events.
So this links to the
resources for you to be able
to see any pod events in the event
that there were particular
issues that you saw as well.
Just sort of consolidating
things even further for you
to have this additional information
when you're carrying
out your troubleshooting
or debugging of issues.
And next up, we're gonna look
at a photo gallery application.
So over here we currently
see that there is nothing.
Might take a little bit of
time, we switch it to 15 minutes
and there's nothing going on here.
So we're gonna switch
to the flow table view.
And what this photo gallery
application is actually doing
is it's essentially just
uploading images to S3
and then storing metadata in DynamoDB.
So if we go to the flow table you'll see
that there are three
perspectives over here.
There's the AWS Service view, which is pod
to an AWS Service.
There's the cluster view which is east
to west traffic within the cluster
and then there's external
view pod to a destination
that is outside of AWS.
Now, in this case we can see here
for our photo gallery
application, we can see the pods
is actually, the pods
that are speaking to S3
as well as DynamoDB.
We can also see the volume
of data transferred.
We can see the local pod
IP and the remote pod IP.
If you wanna modify the
columns that you're seeing,
you can also do that and
customize it for what's specific
and more purposeful
for the way you carry out
your investigations within your team.
Data transfer is one that is
typically really important
for customers to be able to see.
I'm gonna switch to the cluster
view so you can see this.
And for the cluster view, I'll switch back
to the e-commerce namespace.
At the moment here we'll be seeing things
for the photo gallery application,
but we switch back to the e-commerce
and you'll see that now
we're seeing about 300 flows
that are represented over here.
And again, you can change the time range,
and of course the greater the
time range, the more flows
that you're going to have.
For this particular demo,
you'll see it'll probably only go up
by two additional flows.
So we'll see about 302 flows represented.
There you go.
If we switch back to 15
minutes, it's about 300.
And similar to what we
saw when we were going
through the service map,
even here in this flow table,
you can filter further
if you're looking for something specific.
Again, this fits within that
workflow that we pointed out
that I pointed out earlier
where you would've started
from your observability stack,
you would already have some kind of alert
that's giving you sufficient
information to know
what you should be looking
for so that when you come
to the service map or the flow table,
you have enough context
to just accelerate the
troubleshooting process.
As I mentioned earlier as well,
this is something that can also inform
the cost optimization techniques.
Customers are typically
interested in seeing
what traffic is going
from AZ to another AZ.
So that's something you can
also make, leverage here.
And something that's also
especially important in this case
and very relevant for this
particular session is the fact
that you're able to actually track
the traffic behavior within your cluster,
and you can now see, is this aligning
with the network security
policies that I've put in place?
This can now be the key thing that informs
how you define your network policies,
and is especially important
as you're shifting left
and you're doing this essentially
in the dev environment
instead of having to find out
in a production environment
when things are going wrong.
And what we have over here
is the historical explorer,
which essentially launchpads you
to the cloud wash network
monitoring dashboard
where you can see this in the
broader spectrum of things,
and it is especially
important to kind of see
that you now have that
consolidated transparency
between the Kubernetes network plane
as well as the VPC Network
plane as I pointed out earlier.
So you can see over there in
corresponding network path,
you can be able to
correlate a specific flow
that is taking place
within your EKS environment
or your Kubernetes network context
and see how that relates
to the underlying VPC constructs as well,
being able to see the
specific EC2 instance
and the ENI associated with
that flows particular path.
And in here and zoning in particularly
on the Istio ingress gateway.
And we can see the
correspondent network path,
and each one of those flow level metrics
are also visible here.
You'll be able to see the retransmissions,
the retransmission timeouts
as well as the volume
of data that was sent.
If I switch back and now
we can see the photo,
the photo gallery is now
generated in the service map.
And similar to before as I showed
with the e-commerce application as well,
we can see the API gateway is talking
to both the upload service as
well as the gallery service.
And similarly if we want
the more detailed view
where we're seeing flows between
the specific pod replicas,
we can have that represented
as well in the service map.
So all of this is in the tail
end of your investigation
but meant to help in accelerating things.
Now, a key thing that we also see a lot
of our customers doing is making use
of a service mesh implementation.
And the reason why we
wanted to highlight this
as well in this session
is we wanted to know,
we wanted our customers to know
that what we're introducing
container network observability
is complimentary as well,
and in many ways allows you
to be less reliant
on a service mesh implementation
for observability.
We've heard a lot of our customers say
that they would adopt a service mesh
primarily because of observability,
and now you no longer
need to use it primarily
for that, but rather you can leverage it
for other features as well.
And in addition to that, we found
that there would be
sometimes an inconsistency
'cause not every workload
may be running in the mesh.
And so you may have a certain level
of observability at the network
layer for certain workloads
that are in the mesh, but
any workload that is outside
of the mesh doesn't have the
same level of observability.
And now that can change
because you're using container
network observability
that will surface the sufficient
data whether an application
is in the mesh or not.
You can still use your service
mesh for advanced networking
for fine grain traffic control
and an advanced load balancing mechanism.
You can still use it for end
to end encryption like MTLS,
which is a common use case.
And as I already pointed out
for detailed observability,
there's some key metrics that you can get
from service mesh
implementations like Istio.
Envoy emits a lot of great statistics.
But it is also worth noting
that adopting a service
mesh implementation
does typically introduce some
operational overhead as well.
Managing a service mesh
at scale can be something
that's particularly challenging.
And so by introducing container
network observability,
how this helps our customers
is they no longer need
to adopt an entire service
mesh just for a single piece
of it, but rather they can
make better informed decisions
as well and seeing what
capabilities they can actually get
out of the mesh knowing
that they also have
additional native
capabilities provided by EKS
that can help them in their journey.
So we've seen the different layers
that we've been taking over here.
We started off by highlighting
how we were making it easier
for our customers at an operational
layer with EKS Auto Mode
and taking on that responsibility
of managing those core
networking components.
And then Rodrigo also highlighted
the network security
capabilities that can enhance
the security posture
of your environment at the network layer.
But we've also been trying
to drive home the point
of how this is especially difficult
without sufficient visibility.
And now with container
network observability,
you can make more informed decisions
and more accurate optimizations as well.
- How cool is that?
Right?
So now that we know what's going on
in our underlying network,
we can shift left security.
So using that service
map we can understand
what are the pod to pod communication?
What are the east, west,
or even north south com communication?
And we can start narrowing
down the access control.
So let's go back to that
cluster that was broken
with the applications not running,
and let's enable that default deny again.
But at this time we will create
the network policies
based on the rules that we observed
using the network
observability capabilities.
But then you can tell me,
Hey, Rodrigo, I can use GenAI
to create the network
policies for me, right?
I tried that and I have to use
the network observability feature
to really understand what was going on
because the network policies
that the model generated
to me didn't work.
The application was still broken.
So I, I was able to create
the network policies.
Now everything is is there,
you have the cluster running,
the application still running,
but we still have default allow policy.
Now we're going to change that.
So this is what we have done.
So you observed you can use that,
in a development
environment, you can track
and understand your networking map,
you can create your network policies
and then change to a default NI.
And these applications will
be ready to go to production
already, with network policies
already embedded on that.
So that's huge shift left security,
and is a shared responsibility
between both platform security
and application teams, right?
So now we have like the
default NI policy set
that we can have, we can see
that I have several network
policies running on the cluster,
each one with specific things.
And I have the application still running.
I can explore the catalog,
I can put things on my cart
and I can finish buying.
So this study from CNCF
demonstrates exactly that.
If we shift lab security,
the cost to fix a niche,
a security issue in a
development environment
versus a production
environment is 640 times more.
So that's why we should shift
lab security on this case.
So we covered all of those layers,
but then I was talking about
like application development
and shifting lab security
and putting everything
together with the application.
So there's more.
Yesterday we announced it the
managed capabilities for EKS.
So this is a brand new feature
that was just announced it
really yesterday, 4:00 p.m.
So this new capabilities
are managed capabilities
leveraging open source
tooling like Argo CD, KRO,
and ACK, where you can use EKS
to manage your entire platform
and application lifecycle stack.
So this will like be overall
increasing all the velocity
and time to market using all
of these managed features from
the baseline with DKS Auto
to network observability,
network policies,
and now manage capabilities.
So what are the key
takeaways for us today, Luke?
- Thanks, Rodrigo.
So as we pointed out
and have been emphasizing
throughout the session
is what we're seeing is our customers
are creating complex
environments that are increasing
in their distribution,
they're growing in their overall scope,
in their heterogeneity,
and the network is a core
fabric or a critical layer.
And in order to sufficiently optimize
according to whatever your standards are,
you need the right kind of visibility.
In addition to that, we've pointed out
how having the right level
of security in your network
environment is actually going
to enable you to move even faster.
So we hope you see this tire,
or this connection between them.
Informed decisions that
can help empower you
in making the right kind
of tactics for the security
policies that you're going
to be rolling out with
a lot more confidence,
knowing what the expected
behavior will actually be.
And as we've highlighted just
in the previous session with,
in the previous slide, sorry,
that Rodrigo just pointed out
with EKS capabilities, our commitment
is to increasingly simplify
operations for our customers.
And so taking that layered
approach, we can see now
how EKS capabilities
fits into that as well.
So we're very excited for you
to try out these new features,
container network observability and EKS,
and of course
what was just launched
yesterday, EKS capabilities.
Rodrigo and myself will hang
out a little bit after this.
We'd love to chat to any of you
that have particular questions,
and look forward to hearing
about how you use these
features in your environment.
Thanks a lot for coming for the session.
(audience clapping)